the Joe Rogan experience he was weirder
I had like he had my ghost up there
before I was done talking about it
ghost it comes right here's a problem
with ghosts those ghost shows Wow yes
those ghost shows are [ __ ] a hundred
percent one of those guys got in trouble
recently because he made it goes book
and you like plagiarized a bunch of [ __ ]
okay like like blatant like copy and
paste yeah geez yep
it's some of my favourite theaters when
you go right where you go performing
these theaters and you talk to the
people I always asked it was you have a
ghost
mm-hm yeah there was a little boy I was
in was I
Oshkosh gosh gosh and there was an old
theater and the guy who runs the theater
said you know we've had theirs legendary
they keep talking about there's like
three ghosts something and they're
having a cocktail party upstairs in this
like cocktail lounge off the balcony and
his son this guy son ran into the
balcony and he's talking with people and
I gotta go get him and he goes in there
and the kids leaning over the balcony
talking to the stage and having a
conversation with someone he's like yeah
no no that oh this is my dad what he
wants us to go down there he's who wants
us to go that guy he wants us to go down
there there's no one down there the
thought about that with little kids is
that little kids have not dulled all of
their senses with the pressures of the
world and all the other information that
we carry around in our heads and all of
our ideas of what's real and what's not
real and that little kids are open yeah
and then they could see things well umm
flea from the Red Hot Chili Peppers was
talking about that with his son that his
son is like I think it was flea yeah the
Sun is like tuned into spirits in a way
I know that he was looking at it was
like maybe it's that these kids are not
like maybe we all have that in us but
its blunted right by pressures and life
and the lack of sleep and
responsibilities and relationships and
yeah work and fear everything right and
and also like we define how the world is
right we get it in our
this these are the parameters for the
world yes how the world works and that's
it and go to work and [ __ ] button up
your [ __ ] sleeves right there's my
belief yes my belief system is gonna
carry me through yeah yeah this is what
it is the fact there is
[Applause]